QUESTION: So I have been hearing about this project (Pleistocene Park) for many many years.
You guys are finally there and you're seeing it
and you're with George (Church) and other scientists...
I guess my question is did it seem
more or less feasible?
More or less plausible?
More or less achievable?
And what kind of resources are going to be required?
Stewart Brand: That's a perfect question.
Because I was going there looking for that.
And part of it is the sheer competence
of the Zimovs. Both of them.
And the depth of time and commitment they've
made there. That they've got the beginnings of
a real-life demo of... what had been (only) an essay
in Science magazine some while back.
When you have a  density of animals on the land
it really starts to change
in the way that one would be glad of.
And there's always more animals.
Basically the land coming back to life.
But that sheer competence they have. I mean...
They're in such an impossible situation.
All day every day.
From out standpoint.
The fact that they can somehow... I mean
Nikita has stories to tell of getting through
the snow and almost dying...
Being in a situation where he's lost. He's not sure
that he's going in the right direction.
He's frozen... they all have stories like this!
So these are insanely competent characters.
And I trust their science. And I trust
their capability to carry it through.
And a completely different level in the lab.
I feel the same way about George Church.
So this particular project is in such good hands.
And the science think is so well proven at this point
that I believe it will all go forward.
Alexander Rose: I think for me was it was
both sides of this equation.
Both I was stunned to find out how realistic it was
to do the basic science of the project.
And I was also stunned at
how massive the scale of the problem is,
and how immediate that tundra melting problem is.
It was literally the summer we were there, and
the week we were there, the paper was published
around the frozen layer: huge portions of it not freezing.
And after you fly 10 hours across Siberia,
you're like, wow, there's a lot of stuff to do here.
Stewart Brand: So if you can look out if all that
landscape you've been flying over for 10 hours
and think: all of this landscape is
becoming a greenhouse gas problem.
And might be converted over time
into a greenhouse gas solution.
That's big. And it doesn't even include
northern North America yet.
But it will.
Kevin Kelly: I don't have much doubt that
a mammoth will be resurrected. And that it even
could have the effect of clearing Pleistocene Park.
I think it's another level of belief to imagine
it spreading across all Siberia.
I mean, it could.
But that's just another question.
So I think there's different levels of success.
And I think... the close success of making
a version of a mammoth
and having it have an effect within that area,
I think that looks like it kinda could really happen.
Whether it takes off or whether it has the total effect
everybody wants, I think that's much more uncertain.
But I think the first thing seems very plausible to me.
Stewart Brand: Jason and David what did you think?
David Alvarado: Yeah... I mean, you're asking a couple of Millennials if we can edit genes. And I think, absolutely!
You know, to us it's natural, right?
We just grow up in the era of seeing computers change, rapid rapid rapid...
And so this feels very natural, part of
like our timeline of witnessing technology
I think for us as filmmakers...
the thing that we know our audience is going
to be asking is that sort of Jurassic Park question.
"You spent too much time thinking whether you could do it, that you didn’t stop to think if you should!"
Slam the table. Well to us there's
so much more interesting ideas there.
Should we? And what does it mean when humans
both decide to do it, to go forward with that,
or if we decide not to, we choose
not to use technology to
try to safeguard the planet,
I think there's just so much there that
there's not clear answers.
But it should be talked about.